[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
nous vivons et jour assez tendue et la
route est assez difficile
ils sont évidemment pour beaucoup
les troubles suscités
par des agitateurs
qu'il faut réduire et châtiés
certains française digne
se sont lancés dans des entreprises
subversive et criminel
exploitants exaspérant l'irritation et
l'inquiétude d'une partie de la
population d'origine européenne
la nostalgie
de quelques éléments de l'armée
la rancune
et l'ambition de plusieurs chefs
militaires ou politicien disponibles
ces conspirateurs ont essayé et c'est et
sans doute essaieront encore
de créer des bouleversements à la faveur
desquels il imagine se saisir du pouvoir
la nation elle méprise et condamnent ces
gens
leur
complot et leurs attentes à
leur destin
ne relèvent
que des forces de l'ordre de la police
et de la justice le gouvernement est là
pour en répondre
et moi
j'ai pris quand il le fallait au besoin
je prendrais encore
les mesures exceptionnelles nécessaire
agassi twin red adair et c'est qu'on
prix du pétrole ont mené à bien la
première étape de leurs travaux pour
éteindre le puissant jet de gaz qui
brûle dans le désert ils ont débarrassé
le voisinage des amoncellements de
ferraille projetée par l'explosion sous
des jets d'eau continuelle sans lesquels
il n'aurait pu approcher la flamme à
moins de 100 m les hommes ont découpé
les barres d'acier tordus travail
harassant au milieu de l'air surchauffé
et de la vapeur travail dangereuses
morceau par morceau les bulldozer blindé
ont déjà dégagé du voisinage depuis 600
tonnes de ferrailles dont certaines
incandescente aurait pu ranimer la
flamme au moment de l'extinction gaci
twill brûle depuis deux mois n'a t'on
enfin parvenir à l'éteindre
c'est un événement historique qu'on a
célébré à la cathédrale de coutances en
suspendant un pendule au sommet de la
tour vauban admirait et pourtant elle
tourne avait dit jadis galilée mais pour
démontrer pratiquement la rotation de la
terre il avait fallu atteindre
l'expérience qu'au siècle dernier en
1852 léon foucault avait présenté sous
le dôme du panthéon c'est l'expérience
du pendule de foucault qu'on vient de
réitérer à coutances est une trés d'apt
assistance à regarder le style et du
pendule entamé un peu plus à chaque
oscillations les deux talus de farine
disposaient face à face de deux choses
l'une expliquait déjà foucault ou bien
c'est le plan de stimulation du pendule
qui tourne ou bien c'est la cathédrale
or le plan de simulation d'un pendule
demeure invariable donc c'est la
cathédrale qui tourne donc la terre ce
qu'il fallait démontrer
[Musique]
à londres devant l'immeuble du sunday
times les curieux étaient aussi nombreux
que les photographes pour assister à
l'arrivée en coûte 20 du nouveau
conseiller technique du journal
londonien il est vrai que l'engagement
de l'ordre cela donne par ailleurs époux
de la princesse margaret a fait quelques
bruits en angleterre
[Musique]
place vendôme ceux qui aiment les élans
tourmentée du sculpteur atkine peuvent
aujourd'hui découvrir un akin tapissier
11 tapisserie tissée à aubusson tiré de
gouache ou de dessins illustrent cette
nouvelle vocation d'un talent depuis
longtemps affirmé dans les trois
dimensions
zappin tapissier ce sera une nouvelle
arabesques de sa carrière artistique
et l'on pourra suivre de la statue à la
tapisserie la continuité d'une
inspiration très singulière
[Musique]
dans le même temps picasso lui nous
révèle dans une autre galerie ce qu'il
convient d'appeler l'époque vauvenargues
ce sont là les peintures récentes de 59
à 61 toutes datées de son château
provençal certains y trouveront le
rappel de motifs chers au picasso de
1925 et d'aucuns s'attriste seront
peut-être de trouver dans ses toiles des
concessions au figuratif en tout cas un
nouvel aspect de picasso
[Musique]
voici juste deux cent cinquante ans
naissait au château de candiac dans la
plaine languedocienne louis-joseph
marquis de montcalm qui devait être
l'une des grandes figures de l'histoire
du canada français ni les pierres ni le
paysage n'ont changé la fenêtre de la
chambre où il naquit s'ouvre sur un
horizon qu'il connut bien tout au plus
si les vignes ont remplacé les cultures
et les friches de l'époque ses larges
espaces ils les parcouru sous le soleil
avec les galopins de son village et du
petit bois où il joua enfants l'ombragé
toujours le même si les arbres ont été
remplacés
et au moment de son départ pour les
amériques il se retourna sans doute pour
regarder encore cette silhouette
rustique qu'il ne devait plus revoir et
ce fut la grande aventure à plus de
mille lieues de sa patrie il gardera
pendant trois ans le canada contre les
attaques britannique
paris le laisse à peu près sans renforts
essence pour et il finit malgré des
victoires retentissantes par être acculé
dans québec où il s'enferme et qu'il va
défendre malgré l'infériorité de ses
forces
mais le 13 septembre 1759
obligé de livrer bataille il est blessé
à mort est contraint de capituler il
meurt le lendemain en même temps que son
antagoniste général wolfe commandant les
troupes anglaises
québec ad'ailleurs élever un monument
comme à ses deux nobles adversaire
québec parle toujours de montcalm et sur
la terrasse de la citadelle qui domine
le saint-laurent québec évoque encore la
ronde silencieuse de montcalm aux
dernières heures du siège mais notre
pèlerinage d'aujourd'hui ne sera que
celui de ce château rustique perdu dans
la plaine languedocienne est presque
inconnu où il naquit et voici tout juste
deux cent cinquante ans
[Musique]
la normalisation qui a réuni en france
des ingénieurs du monde entier est une
notion moderne la chose existait déjà
pourtant dès l'époque des flèches de
silex et les égyptiens inventant
l'écriture normalisait sans le savoir
[Musique]
l'adoption du système métrique su en
france la première des grande
normalisation et l angleterre songe dans
ce domaine à se normaliser c'est qu'on
échappe pas aujourd'hui à la
normalisation le moindre four de
cuisinière qui n'a pas répondu aux
normes vérifié par le rôti électrique
n'est pas digne de ce nom
[Applaudissements]
mon siège doivent être capables de
supporter dix mille fois le choc de
notre poids
noma plat n'ont pas le droit de se
déformer
nos fers à repasser et tout notre
arsenal ménagers doivent répondre aux
exigences de normes de toutes sortes la
normalisation voilà le secret de notre
bonheur quotidien
si les pompiers de toulon et ceux de
marseille avait pu raccorder leur clio
les galeries de marseille n'aurait
peut-être pas brûler plus simplement qui
ne s'est sentie saisie de désespoir
devant un tuyau à gaz parfaitement
inadaptées à la prise de tel problème
n'existe plus avec la normalisation dont
les règles d'or sont simplification et
efficacité et dont le domaine s'étend de
l'avion le plus moderne à
l'harmonisation d'une bouche de poêle
avec le charbon en sac calibre et
c'est encore la normalisation qui a
substitué aux multiples litres
d'autrefois des livres standard viser
que la ménagère peut faire reprendre par
tous mais attention la normalisation n'a
rien à voir avec certaines prolifération
de bébés normalisé ne veut pas dire
stéréotypé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]